in this video you're going to learn how
to find the equation of a parabola when
you're given the focus and the directrix
so let's see if we can get into this
video and I'll show you how parabolas
work so first of all you know what
basically is a parabola well a parabola
is the set of all points okay
such that if you pick a point on that
parabola and you measure the distance to
the focus and you measure the distance
to a line called the directrix those
distances are always going to be the
same so the idea is if you were to go
further out on this parabola here you
can see the distance to that focus is
getting longer but so is that
perpendicular distance to the directrix
is also getting longer but those points
on the parabola this u-shaped graph okay
there are always going to be equidistant
from a given point called a focus and a
given line called directrix the other
component of parabolas is this distance
between the vertex and the directrix and
the vertex and the focus we call that
distance P and the basic equation of a
parabola is in the form ax squared
equals 4p Y or Y squared equals 4p X now
the thing to realize is that you know
these parabolas can be picked up and
shifted left and right up and down the
way I've written the equation here this
is where the vertex or that bending
point that turning point is at the
origin but you know you can see the H
and K can shift the graph left and right
up and down but the key thing to
remember is that if the X term is
squared that means the parabolas going
to be opening either up or down if the P
is positive its opening up but the P is
negative its opening down and then for
the y squared if you have a y squared
term but not an x squared term that
means it's opening to the right or the
left left if P is negative right if P is
positive so let's get into this problem
and see if we can graph it and write the
equation so the directrix here is at x
equals negative 1 so let's go ahead and
sketch that in so that's just an
imaginary you know invisible line okay
and we'll just write that x equals
negative 1 right there and then the
focus is at 3 1 which is right there
I'll just label that to focus now the
thing to realize is that the vertex is
halfway in between the focus and the
directrix so if we find that midpoint
you can see that's going to be right
here at 1 1 so let me just write that
down the vertex
is that right one up one okay so now the
distance from the vertex to the focus
that distance is our P distance or the
vertex to the directrix that is also P
and you can see that P is equal to two
all right so that's important when we go
to write our equation so it looks like
the parabola is going to be opening to
the right it opens away from the
directrix towards the focus okay so you
can see it's going to be opening
something like this to the right so that
means this is going to be an x squared
I'm sorry a Y squared variety okay so
this is going to be y -1 squared okay
equals 4 times P P is 2 here so 4 times
2 and then X minus 1 so if we simplify
this this is 8 times X minus 1 and this
is y minus 1 squared and there you can
see our vertex is at 1 1 these are at
the opposite sign okay 1 1 and then this
is positive which tells us open to the
right and the other thing that I didn't
mention in in the intro here is is that
the parabola is there actually at the
level of focus therefore P wide okay so
that means for P in this case is 8 so at
level the focus is going to be 8 wide
from here I'm going to go up 4 1 2 3 4
that's a point under graphing down 4 1 2
3 4 and so that gives us an idea about
how wide the parabola is okay like that
so the equation is what we were after
and we've got it right there so I hope
that helped you to make you know finding
the equation of ellipse a little bit
easier when you're given the focus in
the directrix subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon